[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about digital
meditation improving sustained attention
we have dr. David Ziegler joining us on
the show hello hello thanks so much for
coming on of course yeah happy to do it
really excited for this has been a while
since we met about three years ago we
would like yeah we were coming into the
neuro scape office to look over the
technology that we had this you know how
on hololens we had this meditation
application and it was really cool to be
using augmented reality technologies
working
exploring working with you guys at that
and you were still building meta train
and now you actually have it published
in nature human behavior and I'm so
excited to be showcasing a demo with you
today those who don't know David Sigma's
background he's director of multimodal
biosensing at neuro scape and associate
professional researcher in neurology at
UCSF one of his latest projects
Mediterranean proves sustained attention
and young adults through digital
meditation in partnership with jack
Kornfield adam Buzzelli and Zynga and
you can find the links in the by below
to David's in her escape profile as well
as the meta trained pro file on neuro
scape and the full paper in Nature and
David's Twitter and air escapes Twitter
as well
alright David let's start things off
with one of our favorite questions to
ask our guests what are your thoughts on
the direction of our world
yeah well complicated right complicated
confusing a little bit worrisome at
times but still hopeful I mean today you
know I just turned in the news we have
new leadership in England right so big
changes there or you know these things
are are concerning but at the same time
I think that you know we're at a point
where we're making all this amazing
progress and science and yeah so yeah I
mean it's it's a complicated time so I
think that but you know while a lot of
things are worried
in the world I just you know as sort of
a scientist and somebody doing you know
medically relevant research you just
kind of have to forge ahead and hope for
the best so what are the main principles
you think we can embody to help our
trajectory be on a more positive
direction it's a good question I think
well I as a scientist again I you know I
come back to as close as we can get to
ground truth right really looking at
data believing in data believing in that
there are actual you know quantifiable
falsifiable things that are real in the
world and we have to figure out what are
what things are real and what aren't
real and stick to the stuff that is real
right I think that that's that's one of
the most worrisome you know sort of
trends that's it to me happening in the
world right now that we're ignoring
truth right yeah it used to be that we
would tell stories to our tribe because
of inclusive fitness to help each other
and now there's stories being told
rampantly for self-dealing purposes
propaganda misinformation all these
types of things so we need that
inclusive fitness on a global level
again and technologies like méditerranée
'pl feel the interconnectedness well it
can there's a debate about that right so
that's one of the things we approach
this at you know as you said I work at
neuro scape and that's the center where
we're very much trying to bridge
neuroscience and technology because we
think that we can use technology to both
understand the brain better and also
improve brain function but at the other
you know there's a there's a debate
raging about whether technology is good
or bad for society right so we think and
you know as we'll get into some of the
technology that we've developed we think
that if you apply it in the right way
you can actually in
prove you know brain function and then
also you know this will have sort of
ripple effects to society more generally
yeah there's that to the to perspective
on neuroscience plus technology the the
one is everyone's using the smart phones
and the laptops and the things blue
lights beeps taking us away from the
periods of sustained focus on right on
the creative endeavoring that we want to
pursue and then there's technologies
like Mehta trained at get people deeper
into those states of sustained attention
and interconnectedness unity these types
of feelings so how can we limit the ones
that are distracting and increase the
ones that help us flourish or at least
balance them balance them better you fix
some of the business plans the crooked
business plans with bad ones yeah okay
let's talk about your journey yeah where
were you born
mmm-hmm where were you born Michigan in
Michigan southeastern Michigan and then
who were you growing up in the small
town in Michigan how did you get
interested in neuroscience yeah
interesting you know growing up and and
when I actually first went to college I
wanted to be anything but a scientist so
I was adamant that I did not want to go
into science in my head for some reason
you know I had equated like science with
going to medical school and doing this
very sort of traditional journey and I
didn't want you know I was sort of
rebelling against that in a way and so I
started off as you know college as a
German and history major I actually I
took my first neuroscience based class
my freshman year and the idea was I was
going to take this it was called bio
social dimensions of behavior and I
thought it would be an easy way to get
my science credit out of the way lo and
behold the professor was amazing and
inspired me and I fell in love from that
point on with how the brain controls
behavior so I've been trying to figure
that out ever since so massive switch
you know after my first semester but
yeah well what a what a pivotal moment
in life yeah actually having a really
good professor getting really excited
about that brain and behavior and then
so then what about that led you the PhD
was at MIT
hmm
and so what how did that then get you
inspired because did the Pete was the
PhD on this unmasking neural mechanisms
that account for age-related changes in
cognitive control yeah that was pretty
much my thesis for for my PhD and like
let's yeah let's talk about that for a
little bit in those cognitive
neuroscience so the the neuro
therapeutic piece didn't come until more
recently when I when I came here to UCSF
what I did is as a graduate student in
my my PhD training was really basic any
not entirely basic research but more
largely basic research trying to figure
out what kind of brain brain changes
happen is people get older also I did
some work with patients with Parkinson's
disease trying to develop new MRI
technologies to see what's going on in
the brains of these patients and
difficult to image areas and then you
know from there I came out here to Sam
that that was in Cambridge Boston and
then I came out here for my postdoc with
Adams Ali and it was sometime in that
first year we really sort of started
transitioning from basic research to
more what we call translational research
so taking the stuff that we learned from
basic research and trying to apply it
and turn it into some sort of
therapeutic and that's kind of what I've
been doing ever since we still have a
very important basic research program
but we're always looking for those new
ways to to use both neuroscience and
technology to come up with these
translational applications to try to
help people which is really nice because
you know I I often felt as a grad
student it was you know curiosity was
great and that you know I could there's
tons to learn about how the brain
changes as people age but you know for
much of that the story is kind of a
negative one right so there are a lot of
bad things happening and we didn't have
a lot of good advice to tell people how
to you know improve their function and
now it's really nice to kind of be sort
of on the flip side of that word that's
the focus right trying to help people
improve brain function when they have
difficulties and what would you say is
then a one of these core ideas of how
the brain what happens to the actual
neurophysiology inside the brain when
the age-related changes are occurring as
we're getting older yeah what's going on
up there well I think it's hard you know
we're still trying to figure it out but
there's definitely an issue of sort of
noise in the system so a lot of what the
brain does is what we call sort of
signal detection but there's a signal
detection theory but a lot of what the
brain is doing is picking out signals
amidst noise right and you want the
right signals that becomes harder and
harder as people get older because
they're the the sort of tuning of
neurons and neural communication there's
a lot of noise that gets introduced and
it becomes harder to find that sharp
distinction between signal and noise so
you get part of that is you get more
distracted by noisy things in noisy
environments right because there's tons
of noise so one of the big things that
that we that we focus on now is helping
people figure out how to really hone in
on the signal and avoid the noise right
and there are a lot of different
techniques for doing that some of them
can be behavioral techniques some can
actually be sort of neural techniques
you know in training different rhythms
in the brain and trying to improve that
as people get older because those those
rhythms that are important this is
something we actually we studied in in
the Mediterranean study they can get a
little fuzzy as people get older as well
so trying to fine tune those is another
way of potentially improving that
process so then as we get older there
our ability to take in our
neuroplasticity zhan the decline as in
some way well we get older so that's
that's an ongoing there's not going to
Beit about that it used to be safe 3040
years ago it was really thought that
plasticity or you know the ability of
the brain to change only happened when
when people were in
you know developmental period so
adolescence through maybe young
adulthood and then there was largely you
know class or tub
complete loss of plasticity we now know
that brains are plastic throughout until
the day you die right that's that's one
plus it's been easier at what it is
pardon me Aaron it does it gets it gets
more difficult but that's one of the
things you know one of the one of the
things that we're really pushing on if
we find really engaging mechanisms or
try to find really engaging mechanisms
to really push the plasticity when it
gets harder it's still possible there's
still a lot there and that can be done
potentially offset some of those nerve
executive issues that arise yeah that's
a very interesting thing it's like the
more that you practice really tough
cognitive exercises especially in the in
your 30s and 40s and 50s the less
likelihood you'll have of having the
onset of neurodegenerative diseases
that's a very into the same repetitive
activities do things that are
challenging do things that are new do
things that move you outside your
comfort zone and you'll be able to think
better live longer yeah yeah yeah we
call that cognitive reserve so you build
up this sort of Bank of cognitive
reserve or brain reserve too right so
because everything cognitive or
behavioral comes from the brain so yeah
the idea is if you Bank a lot of that
when you're younger as things decline
later you'll still have this buffer that
will help you deal with with some of
that but it you know it also needs to
continue as you get older too so yeah
yeah build up the cognitive reserve yes
yeah yeah okay so then let's do your
okay so you actually had the back the
interest spans through mind-body
approaches meditation yoga other
neuroplasticity based interventions to
improve cognition and well-being in
general and it makes sense because this
kind of leads us into the what is this
this closed-loop digital meditation
right so how long has it been been yeah
how long has it been with Mediterranean
a building a bit lazy I think from the
point where we started building the app
with the folks at Zynga
to publication was just over four years
yeah for the first study we have we have
a you know several other ongoing studies
and and studies that have wrapped up
since then but for the first one that
we're talking about today yeah about
four years so yeah it's a delayed
gratification they don't tell you that
about science but it's like you really
have to be okay with later at af--
occasion yeah yes the ice of ideas that
you can take a concept in that can
usually take again this long long time
you have to make up formal hypothesis
you come up with the way that you're
gonna try and prove it through
especially when you have to make some
digital right then people have to
interact with and then control for all
the other variables in the experiment
and what and then there's actually doing
the design and the engineering of it and
yeah and getting the people in to do the
testing with it over time exactly yeah
yeah yeah this is tough stuff okay
so then okay so then a couple years ago
you guys were in the process of working
with Zynga on taking what was in your
idea and design engineering it and then
you were get piecing together the right
people the people to come in for this
randomized control sure yeah test okay
okay and then now now you walk us
through the process of then what is
going on with the people that are coming
in what are they doing to improve their
sustained intention through digital
meditation we have this demo too
yeah yeah well let me back up a little
bit and like talk about sort of the
rationale behind why we even went down
this road do it so we we were you know
again we're we were a cognitive
neuroscience group and we're really
interested in mechanisms of attention so
how the brain pays attention
traditionally or up until sort of before
the the area when we era when we started
this meditation program a Mediterranean
a lot of what we studied was what we
call external attention or externally
oriented attention paying attention to
things in your environment right and
from from sort of a science perspective
those things are easy to manipulate
we can flashlights and we can make
noises in the environment to try to
distract people and and divert their
attention from someplace but we really
got in interested in internally oriented
attention as well right so directing
your attention to things that are going
on either inside your own body or your
thoughts and the process of how people
got distracted from those as well so
maybe you're you know if you're tuning
in to the this-this-this broadcast right
now but you're also trying to think
about what you're gonna make for dinner
tonight you're you're you're sort of
either multitasking or engaging it you
know having some sort of distraction so
you have this internal distraction as we
you know began to study this we wanted
to come up with a way to sort of help
people train their internal attention to
be more focused and less distractible
right but you know as we were thinking
about ways to do this it was it became
clear right that that we didn't need to
reinvent the wheel right that there was
this practice of meditation that's been
around for for ages yeah but the idea
was to create sort of a modern version
of it and sort of a you know a
technological delivery system so we had
this idea of and also what we wanted to
do we've prior to this you know we we
had been doing a lot of work with
cognitive training games so we we have
developed an earlier publication from
your escape and in nature was on the
newer racer programs restrained
multitasking yeah so we've looked we had
learned a lot over the years about what
makes engaging cognitive training
programs so the idea was well let's try
to make sort of a meditation game right
where we bring principles of your
plasticity and cognitive training to the
table and merge it with sort of age-old
principles of focused attention
meditation right so that was kind of the
basis and so we had that idea and we
tried to build something on our own
which you know is fine we have we have
developers but then we did have this
really nice opportunity to work with
Zynga used to have an arm called
film throbbing arm called Zynga org
whose mission was to create games for
positive social change or or positive
social change I guess what happen to the
phone topic are oh I think it was a
actually don't know it just ran out of
funding I think and and sort of
evaporated unfortunately yeah I know it
is yeah
but they yeah they wanted to work with a
project with us on a project and we
brought this idea to them and then they
basically pulled people who volunteered
time from the company you know a few
hours a week to put in on this project
so we actually had this whole team of
professional game designers who were you
know doing the look giving a little bit
of time but it turned out yeah so we
ended up with a product that was a lot
more polished and you know more bells
and whistles than we would have done if
we were developing it you know just on
our own at least with with our resources
so it was a real treat to be able to do
that so in taking some of these
principles from even like the neural
racer days yeah and then figuring and
even the meditation from from the
origins of our species days right and
then packaging those together in a way
where you're like we're gonna improve
sustained attention right ok and now can
we sing go on the way ok all right all
right yeah let's soulless so yeah and I
mean and then as you said I kind of got
us off the track we did this randomized
controlled trial in these in healthy
young adults and the idea - the idea
behind you in a study in young adults is
more to sort of proof of concept right
young adults if you think about it for
the most part they're kind of at the top
of their game cognitively right we don't
at least you know in terms of when we
think of cognitive decline it doesn't
really happen until you get into like
30s and 40s and that sort of thing so
they're these are people who are doing
really well but at the same time as we
talked about earlier we have these sort
of you know myriad technological
distractions that are
you know all the time media multitasking
is going on constantly in this age group
and they embrace technology too you know
the greatest extent ever right of any
generation so yeah it kind of makes
sense that you know maybe this would be
a type of delivery of meditation that
would appeal to them and you know if we
could then use that to improve attention
that would be HUGE if we could see you
know it attentional improvements in such
a young healthy group it's a big deal
right because then if we can you know
potentially take it to other populations
who actually have impairments and
attention we might even see you know
compounded benefits you know much
greater impact so that was kind of the
idea behind you know doing a study and
healthy young adult what was the age
group of the healthy and adults they
were 18 to 32 1832 yes it's like tech
almost your whole life type people yeah
yeah and multitasking almost your whole
life and yeah yeah so if you can see I
improvements and sustaining attention
with them then right yeah then that's a
big deal yeah okay cool
all right let's jump into it yeah so
we'll try - all right so this is okay
let's see there yeah the home screen
here and prior to any training we have
these you know sort of these
instructions here which are just how the
how the app actually works this is sort
of nuts and bolts
okay one of the key things though is
this we we did we collaborated with jack
Kornfield who is a leader in mindfulness
training he's brought a lot of Eastern
techniques to the Western world and he
worked with us on this he developed a
very short about a five minute
meditation lesson we can hear a little
bit of it here and so he actually
narrated this recorded it for the app
for us which was was the real treat to
be able to work with him and he
consulted all along the way in terms of
like what what aspects
be in here what were the key things that
that should be in here in terms of the
the the actual meditation principles we
also in develop you heard that narration
no okay let's go okay yeah well let's
play the narration fairly traditional
approach to mind sustained attention
attention meditation for sanitation and
inject us some of the narration are all
yeah he so this is about a five minute
narration and then that really sort of
sets the stage and then the the rest of
the training I'll walk you through so
what a person would do as they go
through there when they when they enter
into the app for their actual training
they would go and we have of course
we're scientists we asked some survey
questions how distracting with iron are
you right now
extract environment yeah if you're in a
roaring loud place you only slept a
little bit of time and you're
caffeinated I mean that exactly
completely different yeah yep yeah so we
collect those data each time and then
they go in and you can see down at the
at the bottom of the screen there there
are these tips so each day they got a
meditation tip again we developed those
with jack in terms of you know things
that that would you know if you say went
to a retreat or took a class with Jack
these are things that he would tell you
during you know the course of your
training as you sort of advanced so we
tried to have you told those in
beautiful music yeah really nice very
important that soon good yeah sort of
setting the stage calming relaxing very
much like you're eating ray up for a
meditation yep yeah absolutely and then
when you're ready when you feel settled
you know we tell them again in Jack's
narration he gives sort of a process to
go through to settle your body find the
the position that works well for you for
sitting where you can sort of maintain a
comfortable position for a little bit of
an extended period of time
one of the things that that does
differentiate this from a more
traditional meditation practice is that
we do kind of chunk it into smaller
segments to make it so for novices we
make it very easily digestible so
they're little chunks of meditation and
then as people get used to the practice
and get more comfortable and improve
their attention we extend the amount of
day they sustain their that they engage
in the practice it's only a couple
minutes to start again it's actually the
so they start with a five-minute period
but it's broken up into the first trial
is only twenty seconds so we just ask
them just twenty second twenty seconds
which is actually really hard time yeah
it's even hard for me stick yes yeah did
you not wander you're ten point in sec
yeah focus on just your breath for
twenty seconds and we recruited people
who were complete novices right so they
had no experience with meditation so
ever that because that would have
actually complicated things if we had
people mixed in who already had a
practice yeah so we were very careful
about that
so once you've settled you go in and the
basic idea is to sit with the tablet in
your hand eyes closed okay and this will
go on for I have this set up for demo so
maybe 20 seconds
right and so after you hear the chime
after that was maybe 15 seconds you just
indicate with the button press whether
you were able to maintain distracting
your attention or not so I'll say yes
okay and then it's self reporting it is
yeah in this in this version we use
self-report which is actually we you
know we've had lots of discussions about
this interesting and then you go for
another round you do yeah I have this
set a very short amount for demo
purposes they would do more it would
continue that and it would be for five
minutes they would continue those trials
and then they would have a little break
like this oh okay and then they would go
back in another five minutes okay okay
yeah okay so you do a couple of okay so
it's maybe about like yeah 20 seconds
there's just full 40 seconds of her per
trial exact say yes or no right so
basically if your mind wanders even one
time then you say you didn't sustain
your time exactly and then that's where
I don't know it's it's tricky and then
that's actually where the the
closed-loop part of the equation comes
into play so you have the Orton
algorithm if they say you know if they
can't maintain their focus we make it a
little shorter if they are able to
maintain focus we make it a little
longer and we use that we use a sort of
standard algorithm from psychophysics
literature that that adjusts it to keep
people performing at about sort of 75 to
80 percent so that they're they feel
like they're able to do it but it's
still challenging I'm just a little bit
and pushing them you know into the flow
state yeah yeah exactly trying to get
the end but tailoring it to each person
some people just you know they're gonna
kind of hover down at pretty low numbers
for a while until they move up other
people you know just kind of take off
right away so we we can very quickly in
the course of say the first day or two
we sort of the algorithm tailors itself
to where the person is at and then from
there we just kind of gently nudged them
up over the course of six weeks so
that's how long they ultimately trained
six weeks and daily five days a week and
yeah bout so we started twenty minutes a
day for the first two weeks moved to 25
minutes for two weeks and then 30
minutes in the last two weeks
exactly yeah okay and not a ton of time
but it's it's comparable to sort of uh
you know some daily meditation practices
that people would have yeah and
self-reporting is an interesting part of
this as well in the future if we can
actually get the biomarkers for right
we've talked about this two years ago
yeah yeah so that's there's actually a
really interesting we have it we've had
a debate amongst ourselves about this as
well you could use like the muse
headband is good right and and other
there are companies out there that
they're out there that are trying to key
in on be it neural signals or some some
physiological signal of relaxation or
being an attentive state I also have
another collaborator at UCSF who's
trying to do that with that from RI so
you know actually going into neural
networks and figuring out can we predict
whether somebody's in attentive state
are they focusing on their breath or on
another part of their body and it looks
promising fMRI is pretty expensive so
it's not going to be an at-home
technique yeah but one of the things
that we decided with this is that the
introspection is actually a really
important property of it learning to
introspect we think it's probably
important part of this as opposed to
having an algorithm or or you know sort
of um yeah maligne machine learning
algorithm that does it for you and
predicts where your brain is yeah you
learning to figure out where your
attention is is something that people
don't actually it's a skill that they
don't sort of yeah normally right
usually it's just a monkey mind taking
you around yeah for exactly and so if
you actually interesting so the idea
that you're even being aware of your own
attention right that it's uh could be
even more important than everything else
yeah and we don't yeah we think that
that's a really critical component of
this and that was something again that
came through conversations with jack
Kornfield about I don't know like what
do we want this to be completely
self-report what level of reporting you
know do we there are different
approaches right do we interrupt people
and ask them what they're worth where
their focus was or do we just kind of
let this play out you know
at a self-paced way and we we just felt
felt that that was closer to what sort
of a more traditional practice would be
like and that that's really kind of the
foundation learning to be introspective
about where your attention is once you
can do that then you can hone it and
focus it to where you want it to be and
avoid the discussions yes so yeah we
kind of like advancing through yours
yeah yeah we're we're leveling up our
ability to be in control of our own
attention absolutely and is that is that
all that we think is good there's more
so okay in a moment I just want to say
one more thing because for so many
people I think it's probably most
relatable with the way that we now have
these habits of women the technological
devices have made the habits I think a
little bit more we're a little we're
over indulging a little bit more than I
think we even used to I think one of the
main overindulgence is used to be things
like food maybe where you go and just
kind of like all of a sudden you'd be at
the fridge again and you'd be like I'm
not even why am I here
yeah you know and so then are you aware
that you're being brought to the fridge
and that you're going to eat yeah that's
really good yeah and like what the
technology device is now it's now it's
like you had a moment of solitude and
before you knew it you were opening up a
social media platform right you can and
so are you aware that you're grabbing
your device in your moment of solitude
and opening up a social platform instead
of allowing periods of free association
yeah to occur so yeah those are probably
the two most familiar I think for tons
of people so yeah basically doing things
like this like Mediterranean get you to
to be more aware of where your attention
is going and pause guys but be more
aware and pause and say do I actually
want to do
right that yeah that's so valuable
sometimes there are periods when you
want to just sort of let your mind
wander right that's where you know so
it's you but it's it's it's again being
in control of where when and where you
allow that to happen right so you have
yourself and where you want that happen
yeah okay cool let's see Alison so just
a few other things you so again we you
know you would you would go through that
for about 20 minutes a day some of the
other aspects of the app or fairly you
know we have a calendar for tracking
weather you you know which is so pretty
yeah yeah very nice days you yeah yeah
yeah the other really neat thing which
again really differentiates this from
say traditional meditation practice is
that we have quantifiable metrics of
your self yeah Jen oh so you know when
when you it you know if you go to a
meditation retreat or two to some sort
of class you might have sort of a sense
for how you're doing yeah but here we're
actually able to quantify it because
we're collecting the data and you know
this you know has never been done before
inter and within sort of a meditative
practice so it's pretty exciting to
actually be able to see and then this
this opens up new doors for feedback to
people and not everybody responds you
know very you know in the same way to
quantified feedback but there is a
subset of our population especially
eighteen to thirty year olds who are
really into sort of the quantified self
collected data about everything now you
know that they're doing it and here we
have data about their internal attention
which they probably never seen before
yeah so so it can we find it can be very
motivating to some people right to see
like oh man I had a really bad day what
was going on you know what do i what can
I do in my next day of training to kind
of try to improve that or maybe I was
having a great day that felt great you
know I'm really motivated to come back
in the morning and do this again so so
it's kind of neat to be able to do that
and then this is then final meditation
time so this is when the closed loop
system figures out how did they get that
day how long did they
yeah because if you you know if you
click no then it brought your final
meditation time exam from 20 seconds to
17 seconds that you can make that happen
yep if you succeeded it made me brought
up to 23 30 etc so that's how what
you're looking at exactly not yes or no
but the final exam yeah yeah yep and you
can see um so a full day view our full
view or a three day whew yeah so this is
the full view that this basically would
sort of aggregate over time so as you
went through the full 30 days you'd see
30 dots on here I just kind of put this
together before I came in for a demo
gotcha she's a 30 dr. exactly okay
versus a three-day view so cool so this
quantified self metrics there's your
nice little Union calendar for right now
you're doing it okay cool basics it's
fairly straightforward and you know
again I think I started off by saying we
we've called it a meditation game it's
there are principles of cognitive
training games in it but it's more of an
app right so it really isn't it's it's
it's not gamified to the to the point
where we might do a future version of it
that that would be and what's the what's
the difference between what
Mediterranean right now and what calm or
headspace yeah or any of the other
players are doing well a big difference
is that we're really focused on the the
focus of the sustained attention aspect
of it we don't really have we don't we
haven't built in a lot of the
mindfulness components to it because we
really wanted to you know we were
interested in sustained attention so we
really wanted to you know have sort of
you know laser focus on sustained
attention and what can we do to really
really target sustained attention so we
kind of took all the mindfulness stuff
out of the out of the equation apps like
headspace and calm really emphasized the
mindfulness which is it you know we
think that they're probably have
complimentary effects on the body and
well be
so one of the but one of the interesting
questions that we had and again you know
we talked through this with with jack
Kornfield and developing it is that you
know a lot of a lot of the philosophy
behind traditional Eastern teachings of
meditation is that you really need to
start with the sustained attention and
then from there you can build out to
these other pieces like you can add the
mindfulness much more easily you can add
compassion more usually been harm at it
exactly but if you don't have that sort
of folk that that sort of foundation of
the sustained attention those things you
can come at it from a different way but
it's much harder at least that's the
theory it's like there would be a debate
about opening sharpening your ability
with your attention first and then I can
go do all the other yeah yeah and
actually right now we're building a
second version of this app where it uses
all the same sort of underlying nuts and
bolts and algorithms but is focused on
training compassion as well that's our
step that we're building that okay so
things like headspace and calm maybe
they don't have this maybe the closed
loop they definitely don't have the
closed so there's no me answering if I'm
yes or no sustaining my tension there's
no them changing my time run yeah based
on how well I'm doing these types of
things so that's more like you just
click a button and then you just let the
music play and okay so that this is a
big difference and then and before we
get to just some of the other slides on
the results then is then one of the
goals ends for me to be able to download
this on Android and iOS yeah for me to
be able to use to in so state attention
that I mean ultimately we would we would
love to have this become a
commercialized app where we're a
research laboratories Research Center so
we're not actually in the business of
putting apps out to the market mostly
because you know we can't support them
at scale right so it's if we would have
to have much more staff in order to do
that so right now there isn't a way to
download this it's a research tool we're
applying it to new research populations
and again we're talking with people
you know the idea hopefully would be to
find some company that would like to
license it and take it to market right
and do all of that sort of work that
we're not you know we don't have the
expertise to do that so unfortunately
there's gonna be a little bit of a lag
but we would like to at some point see
that happen yeah I highly interviewed I
highly recommend people watching right
now to figure out who's the right person
to license this yeah yeah yeah please
get this out help neuro scape get this
out as soon as possible Gerry well this
is a such an important tool that can
just help us gain our own sovereignty
over our own attention and guide and
create endeavouring in the world yep
let's um okay so let's show the let's
show the the assets that we have so okay
so we kind of talked about this a little
bit we went through the demos background
stuff okay cool and so then the next one
so this is I went through a little bit
of this this is just you know sort of
the details of the study that we ran
that was the most recent publication so
we went over the the amount of training
the key thing here is again so these are
healthy older adults to see their
average ages in the 2020s
and then they came in before and after
that six weeks of training for an
extensive selection of the sort of
cognitive tasks so that we could really
figure out what their baseline levels of
attention impulsivity working memory and
distractibility were and then we also
did all these newer recordings so we
looked at the structure of the brain the
function of the brain with EEG we looked
at the structure and function of brain
deg okay but then what are the
normalized tests that people do for
understanding attention and working
memory and impulsivity like how do you
sure yeah what are those tests
yeah so I'm imagining you like dangling
a fruit in front of my face while I'm
like trying to focus on something my god
so it's that is it's a little more sort
of fine-grained than that right so
actually why don't you
go to the next slide okay have a yeah so
if you look on the left over here this
is one of these tests and we call this
the this is the test version of the test
of variable attention Tovah
towba just a variable attention and and
the basic it's a very very simple task
right so the idea is you have you're
supposed to maintain your your gaze on
that little that plus sign in the middle
of the plus sign and you see a box
flashing either the top or the bottom of
the screen okay in one version of the
task the box flashes a lot and you need
to keep responding until it flashes on
the bottom and then you have to withhold
your response okay so what am i pressing
a button yeah so oh I'm pressing the
spacebar something yeah okay okay so
then the box is flashing on the top and
I'm pressing the spacebar and then once
the box moves to the bottom I stopped it
with whole withhold yeah okay but you've
been pressing so much so fast that it's
really hard to stand so if you press
that's a measure of impulsivity right
you made this impulsive response because
you you were you were just kind of going
with the flow
that's an interesting test and then the
other version of it is where you don't
respond you see lots of flashes but you
only respond to the time that it flashes
on the bottom of the screen so you're
ignoring its flashing flashing flash and
you're not responding responding to
anything but every so often only about
20% of the trials do you see it flash on
the bottom and then you have to respond
so that's really sustained attention
because you're having to attend to the
whole thing while you're not doing
anything and watch for that one one time
yeah that it's gonna go to the bottom of
the click then yeah woah yeah so okay oh
interesting it kind of it does inverse
even away and that inverse can yeah yeah
I'll show you both sustained attention
on kind of both these sides of sustain
exactly yep not doing anything and then
doing it and then getting it all the
time is that stopping doing right that's
so interesting
see these are these are cool tests yes I
mean we're humans out there and think
about these tests we spend a lot of time
so this is one that has been
the literature for a while you know it's
a fairly standardized one some of the
other ones that we develop a lot of
these tasks I don't have an example of
one that we developed ourselves in this
slide deck but we spend a lot of time
trying to figure out what is a highly
controlled way that we can measure this
cognitive process that we're interested
in and see if it changes over time so
you know we do we do a lot of the the
development of these and I mean you know
probably almost as much time to spend
developing these tasks as developing
these training apps and interventions so
yeah equally important you've got to
make sure that all the people that
you're doing the randomized control
trial with that beforehand you're doing
a good job at understanding who who they
are how well they have sustained
attention how well there were areas
because then you're trying to compare
the data after Mediterranea okay and if
you're not measuring the right thing
yeah you're not gonna know if it really
which we actually think that you know in
the cognitive training literature there
are lots of null effects where people
don't find big effects and part of it is
that maybe the the training intervention
that they gave was not nearly as
engaging as the type of things we would
develop but also that I think a lot of
times people are picking the wrong
outcome measures right so there are just
things that have huge practice effects
so you know it doesn't just be by virtue
of doing it twice you're gonna get
better on it so we spend a lot of time
you know sort of piloting and debugging
and figuring out what exactly is the
right test of the process we're
interested in so that we know if it does
change interesting and you may have even
had to do this leading up to them oh
definitely I'll try it yeah yeah a bunch
of time so we take a whole other sample
of people who don't do an intervention
but they come in and they do these tests
two or three times just to see just what
are the practice effects you know what's
the baseline level of change what's the
baseline level change right and you have
to like subtract that baseline level
change that's one way of doing it we
didn't do it in this study but in this
study we took what's called a placebo
control so we had another group who did
trained they did all the tasks and they
trained with other apps that we thought
didn't have any
the active ingredient of Mediterranean
they were just kind of off-the-shelf
apps that were were similar enough then
people reported that they felt they
would they would likely improve their
function or they would get benefit from
doing them but we didn't think that it
had any of that active ingredient in it
and then I think the one that so many
people are used to is the delayed
gratification of the marshmallow yeah so
so these are really interesting that
that you have to develop these
measurements before hit four beforehand
and afterwards them to make sure that
you're that what you're doing is having
a serious effect yeah positive effect on
people on the right-hand side yes these
are the the data that we were probably
most excited about so again you've got
this task where you have the the
impulsive version and the sustained
attention version because of what we
were doing we focused more on the
sustained attention version of this of
this test they did both but so as we
talked about earlier young adults top of
their game they're doing really well
cognitively we so if you look at their
performance on hitting the button
they're close to like you know ninety
ninety-five percent accurate right
that's what we call a ceiling effect
they can't really get much better than
that but yeah so we don't have a lot of
room for them to change in terms of
their accuracy right but what we can
look at is this really key measure of
consistency in their performance that we
call it as you can see here response
time variability so your response time
is how quickly you press that spacebar
right when you see the the the target
event right a target event yeah so you
if you if you respond usually we think
of fast response times it's good because
you were quick to get the response right
the faster the better that's kind of
like the Western view right so if you're
pressing the button fast on some trials
it means you're sort of you're engaged
in you're doing the task pretty well but
say your start thinking about something
that aren't those little boxes on the
screen you know you start thinking about
what's gonna be for dinner or you know
all that traffic you had on the way in
here and you're annoyed and so you get
distracted and now you have
a couple of slow responses because you
weren't completely on task and then you
get back to the task and you're fast
again but then you start mind-wandering
again and you get slow what happens
there is you have variability in your
response time you're fast on some trials
and then you're slow and you're fast and
slow yeah but if people are consistently
responding either fast or slow or
whatever they're their optimal speed is
for the task if they're consistent and
they don't show these fluctuations from
fast to slow to fast to slow that we
actually take is an indicator that
they're sort of in the zone and they're
really focused on the task and their
mind isn't wandering to other events and
there's a lot of literature that sort of
supports this idea so the lower your
variability in your response time the
more workers yep and so if you look at
the bars here's the black box with heart
rate variability to the lower the heart
rate variability actually the more
focused but the more yeah it's like the
more the more fight-or-flight yeah you
exactly yeah it goes down when you're in
that mode and then the variability hurts
that's a complicated but yeah it almost
it's a little counterintuitive sometimes
but yeah so yeah the variability the
more focused here in this case yeah and
what you can see the the black bars are
the groups so Mediterranean is on the
left and the placebo control here is on
the right
they were pretty much matched before the
training but after training the
mediterráneo tas ignition their
variability so they became more
consistent from moment to moment from
their task performance and the other
group didn't show any change got it so
that was really the and then we actually
I don't think I have the other slide out
here okay that's cool so you learned
that they increase their sustained
attention through response time
variability exact that they were more
focused get more consistent and get
response times okay yeah and we actually
found the exact same find the exact same
effect on a completely separate task
so another task called the filter task
where you have to I don't have I don't I
didn't put that one in here but you have
to look at different bars and sort of
ignore things that are just
acting in on the screen so it's a little
more complex yes but you have to
maintain some items in memory filter out
the distracting things and then respond
to to whether there was a change and
their response time variability
decreased on that task as well so it's
kind of like you know within the same
group we have this little replication on
two different tasks which really
increases your yeah you know the the
trust that you have in the final yeah
because you had to store all of that
information and working memory that you
stood yeah say whether or not anything
changed right what is that one called
that was the filter task
it's called filter talent or test yeah
because you're filtering the ideas
you're filtering out irrelevant stimuli
yeah yeah yeah cool okay so then they
increased on both of these tag exactly
okay cool
then is there something else about the
bottom right there's just another way of
plotting the data so with what you can
see there's the response times sort of
in the in the gray bars that's the meds
after training so you can see that peak
kind of sharpens yeah in the
Mediterranean OTT the placebo group that
pretty much stays the same so that's
just basically showing that they're more
consistent and they're sort of
fine-tuning their their stability of
attention so so your training chimps to
have improved editors and reviewers like
to see data in many different ways
that's why we yeah we had like you know
probably four more panels to this this
graph in the paper if you when you go to
the actual publication yeah okay cool in
a dated different ways okay all right in
the next one I think yeah and so these
are this is just a little bit from that
from the neural data that we recorded
from the EEG data and so again we
collected this electroencephalography
where you put electrodes on the scalp
and you measure the sort of underlying
electrical activity of the brain and one
of the ways that you can quantify this
is in terms of different brain rhythms
yeah and I think I mentioned we've
talked about this toward the toward the
intro to the interview one of the
rhythms that's really important for
attention is this theta rhythm so it's a
four to seven Hertz oscillation
so the idea is if you have neurons that
are active all active together and then
they're all silent and they're all
active and then they're all silent that
can take on a sort of periodic function
or a rhythm so like a sinusoidal wave
and so you can fit the waves to that and
you assign it a different frequency in
this case four to seven Hertz and so you
can kind of see that over on that on the
left you see the frequency is on the on
the y axis on the far left and then you
have over time here you see on the on
the x axis that's a time frequency plot
and you can see this sort of big block
of four to seven Hertz activity around
two to three hundred milliseconds what
and then what does that indicate
and so that's indicating that's about
the time when we think that people are
really paying attention to whether the
target happened or not and deciding to
make a button press yeah so it's the
point at which there either you know
committing to the button pressure not
okay and so if they're really focused we
should see we think and the sort of
literature backs us up that there should
be more of this theta oscillation in
these frontal regions here so this is
the front of the brain you can't see the
back of the brain interest but basically
you were seeing in sort of the lateral
or side frontal areas and also the
medial or middle frontal areas this
increase in the theta synchrony so do we
think that the at anytime of sustained
attention that we should see theta
synchrony in the frontal lobes it's we
this is about the the well it varies
from task to task but you should see it
at some point after the visual system so
you have this this was a visual task
they're seeing things out on on a
computer screen so the visual
information has to go through the eyes
to the visual cortex so you have low
level processing that has to be done
then a little bit later about 200 or 300
milliseconds later is when you we expect
to see some of these higher-order
centers engaging to make some sort of
decision about the task so you really
you wouldn't expect to see this really
early in like the first hundred
milliseconds yeah because the visual
system is still taking in the
information and sending signals out to
higher level brain
yeah then they engage and if they're if
they're attuned to the task and they're
attending you should see this theta at
that point okay okay and so one of the
interesting so the theta rhythm itself
is is is great and important but the
particular way that we measured it is
yeah I do have it written out here is
what we call inter trial coherence and
so coherence is just synchrony or
synchronized oscillations but this is
was really important because basically
what this means is that the the
alignment of the start of the theta
oscillation is from trial to trial as
they're going through this task it's
becoming more consistent in the people
who did Mediterranean not in the people
who did the placebo so that's what the
the bar graph is showing your coherence
is increasing so this is hearin some end
of the rhythm yeah the start of the
rhythm is becoming more consistent
that's so that's the inner trial
coherence and basically it's kind of
like a neural analogue to increasing
your moment to moment or decrease in
your moment to moment our key
variability so it's kind of like we
think that these are very very similar
processes so this is you know what we
think is the underlying neural mechanism
so by the you know behaviorally we see
that people are more consistent in their
performance but also in the brain this
this theta oscillation is becoming more
consistent from trial to trial and sort
of the same way interesting okay so
before there was more dissonance exactly
there and then then you got coherence
towards this theta oscillation yes
that's you think the narrow underlying
physiology this one a sustained again at
least one yeah yeah okay cool so that's
the main data there are a couple other
things in there but you know we can
those are kind of the really take the
big take up messages from from that one
and then what's this one yeah yeah this
one is just a different way of looking
at a EG data it's what we call erp or
event related potential and it's
basically instead of looking at the
oscillations and kind of just three B
yeah that's it that's a bit of a
complicated one yeah you guys are so I
know we lose this area it's like the do
PFC when you when you break it down it's
actually pretty easy P means positive
okay three means it's at three
approximately 300 milliseconds okay and
B they're different so there's a p3 a
which happens early in the 300
millisecond window and then a B that
happens late in the 300 millisecond
window so positive 300 millisecond and
happening a little later yeah ear peas
are yummy do people spend lifetime
studying all these different different
related related things put p potential
attentional so the electrical potential
electrical potential and basically what
you can see here is that so the 300 it's
like this window right here so you can
see that there's this there's the
difference in the curves in the
Mediterranean not so much in the labs
probably blocking the camera and not so
much in the placebo group there's 300
millisecond window okay that's something
okay okay okay okay I see so it's okay
so at the 300 millisecond window there's
pre and post there's a bigger gap
exactly down to placebo so it's there's
a bigger gap and it's what it's slightly
doing to is it's the the latency or the
the speed at which the p300 sort of
ramps up is getting quicker in
Mediterranean the Mediterranean to the
placebo group so that's that's what
we're so they're they're engaging their
control mechanisms their attention
mechanism faster during games in the
trial compared to the the other group
yeah
and now this is happening in a very
different part of the brain so this is
showing sort of a top-down view of the
brain this is the front and this is the
back we see this more in what we call
sort of parietal regions posterior
parietal areas so we think that you know
we didn't really have the power to do
sort of modeling of the frontal parietal
interactions but we think that these are
probably sort of in
you know there's sort of interplay
between that frontal theta rhythm that's
then driving what's going on back here
at this sort of because that was at 200
milliseconds this is a little later at
300 milliseconds so there's probably the
the sort of interaction between the
frontal and parietal regions that is
important okay and then what did that in
that interaction is signaling well that
so this we think this is another marker
of sustained attention so if you have
this you know the bigger and faster your
p300 your parietal lobe is engaged
especially for visual spatial that's
kind of what the parietal lobe does
these this visual spatial attention yeah
you know if we had used a verbal task it
would be different areas but that is
yeah then the more you're likely
attending to a challenge that your focus
yep okay and that's why yeah the
parietal in this case yeah yeah okay the
brain stuff yeah I mean the the we're
really interested in the neural
mechanisms but it gets really
complicated very quickly but yeah that
makes yeah it tracks with the behavior
results pretty well yeah yeah you you
will see the areas of the brain engaged
and focused that's right you're looking
at yeah okay yeah so many contributors
and colleagues shout out okay this is
for team R and Lindsey Martin Sacha
Skinner everybody yeah yeah Abby Spade
Jim Stern or Zynga shout out shout out
everyone shouts all around for all the
people involved yeah it is nice to show
cuz you know again for you know over
four years and this is the type of you
know team that it takes to do this type
of study it's it's a huge amount of
coordination so I you know and again
they you know and our participants of
course and shout out those are those
were this is one of our older adults so
this is a study that we were actually
just now 10 year old 18 year old yeah
exactly
now where this is from our current study
that we're just now wrapping up and
doing data analysis on
their study yeah we did a much larger
study in healthy older adults in a row
yeah whoa so we were just finishing that
looking at the data looks pretty good
looks like we actually have nine over at
least a partial replication of what we
saw on young adults a world in these
older grandma and grandmas and grandpas
with increasing attention well and this
is a I mean that's a population that you
know they have challenges to their
attention anyway so and then we think
this could be really useful you could
auction you could actually end up saving
you know potentially even like billions
of dollars on health care expenses by
people not needing to go in for
neurodegenerative
yeah yeah that's pretty interesting yeah
yeah through just something as cool and
democratize this digital neuro
therapeutic right that's awesome yeah
that's so cool we we think it's a huge
new you know Avenue that that you know
not completely unexplored but the
digital therapeutics a lot of what's out
there now hasn't been sort of validated
to the level that we're doing it at
neuro scape so that's where you know I
think that there's room for improvement
there's massive potential for these
digital therapeutics but they're also
you know there are a lot of you know
there's a lot of overhype exaggerated
hype exaggerated claims where they
people don't often have as much of the
science to back it up so that's where
we're trying to really sort of figure
out you know at a very sort of minut
level what's going out what are the
mechanisms that are driving this and you
know what what are the aspects of the
training that are more been most
beneficial and then how do we tailor it
to individuals so that not every you
know it's not like a pill that everybody
takes the same pill and it's supposed to
you know have the same effect we know
that isn't how medicine works but it's
how we don't we know that's not how the
body works but it's how medicine works
right up until now so the idea behind
this is tailored to the individual much
more yeah tone way more tailor than
original not just yeah throwing
pharmaceuticals in people's throats and
hoping for the best this is an actual
Taylor experience plus it's also crazy
that this is applicable for an
only you know young people to focus on
sustained attention and be able to
execute what their dreams are better but
it's also for and not needed like dose
up on pharmaceuticals to deal with their
you know which is e th you never problem
right you grow a huge problem growing
concern and then also on the older side
of folks as well to not need to go in
for dementia or any other types of yeah
generative diseases and you can actually
uh maybe you want to do something new in
terms of art or music or science later
in your life and you can sustain your
focus better on that than just clicking
on some channel that yeah yeah right
sapping away the energy the later points
in your life so yeah so that's kind of
the future of neuro tech is these these
digital neuro therapeutics I think it's
it's a big component of it yeah I think
that there are other things to you know
that we're exploring as well neuro
stimulation you know neurofeedback in
general you know we talked about that we
were you know at some point we'd like to
develop a version of this that is driven
the closed-loop is driven by a neural
signals as opposed to that's great you
know again we the question remains open
how much of the introspection is
important to it but once we have that
capability we could actually ask that
question maybe they're good for
different populations
some people might I mean I have a whole
I have a really difficult time with
seated meditation and since focusing on
my breath it's really difficult for me
so maybe I could get much more benefit
from something that's just helping me
relax and get into a state where you
know my body feels better and my mind is
more calm even though you know I'm not
pushing it myself so yeah probably this
isn't for everybody you know and you'd
like you said like the muse headset
isn't for everybody but maybe that would
tap into you know a different population
who benefit will benefit in a different
way yeah it's interesting seeing how
many of the players are at play here
like could méditerranée license go into
headspace or calm or like sam harris is
on yeah yeah I know
why not yeah it could be complimentary
it's not gonna it's not gonna displace a
lot of what these plates what these
other companies comment mention exactly
yeah it's like they'll have a little
drop down for sustained attention
actually yeah exactly
open art and instead of they'll have a
closed loop system your closed loops is
right in there right I like that a lot
Muse could use it all these different
yeah and then they could also do the
portion of the sensing through eg first
yeah determining if you're focused or
not yeah then it's not self reporting
mmhmm yeah yeah yeah let's get this done
let's get this done this is awesome
let's get as it democratizes get this
license and out there yeah yeah I hope
and it's people watching wants to do
that or share it with people that want
to do that I would we would love that
happen and if you do want to go and you
know check out David's link in the bio
and reach out to him via email and just
inquire cuz that's a that's such a good
way to get this out there faster okay
let's let's wrap on uncle points do we
cover what we yeah I think I'm gonna do
a lot of the details yeah that was great
that was cool I liked it too a couple
questions on the way out
the first one is David do we come from
somewhere else into these flesh vehicles
to play on earth I don't think so no I
think that they're we don't know right
but there seems to be a lot of evidence
that the our bodies are put together in
a way that you know what our mind and
our cognition is is this emergent
property right that it it's kind of a
lot of luck the things came together the
way they did and you know but it's not
just yeah I mean coming from somewhere
else it's not to say that there aren't
others like us or you know a different
form of us somewhere else so who knows
but yeah
it's just um you think it's most Occam's
razor just emerged from a lake that's
from the planet like my you know based
on what I know you know I'm not
you know an expert on sort of
evolutionary theory that sort of thing
but humans honor I have said it yeah
yeah exactly yeah I think that's you
know Occam's razor oh yeah yeah some
very spiritual people are like oh we
come from source and we come through
these bodies for school on the pusher
which kinda interesting you know there
yeah and you can't refute that so you
know there it's not you know I don't
have evidence against that Pope yes
again there's a scientist that yeah I
mean it that that the spiritual thing is
I mean they're they're important that
there are very very important
ramifications of that but those are
those are questions that are just not
falsifiable so they're just we have to
live with some unknowns right yeah I
think that's in the the realm of that
yeah science giving some space to
spirituality and like testing that is
well yeah exactly
yeah and I mean again that's like you
know what what we've done here with with
Mediterranean is create sort of a new
digital version of meditation but a lot
of the research on sort of Eastern
practices they're you know these are you
know it's all been proof of what people
have you know known for ages and ages
you know or have suspected for ages and
ages that you know we're just trying to
quantify it and and put scientific data
to it yeah yeah yeah we talked about
that before yeah yeah what's the most
beautiful thing in the world last quite
okay
well I would have to say nature in
general I'm trying to come up with like
one app one example of nature but I just
think that being in nature in so many
different you know work we're in
California here there's there's so much
about being in natural environments
that's restorative that you know I think
it's the most those are the most
beautiful places that that I spend time
on this world anyway yeah thank you so
much for coming on David absolutely yeah
this great huge pleasure yes thank you
great thank you thank you for all your
work with you got a train yeah and we're
keeping continuing on we've got lots
more to do yeah yeah we love neuro skip
we would love oh you know everyone check
out the links in the bio because neuro
skip has so many we do like this one
very minimal slices yeah and let's keep
featuring more of neuro escapes
technologies on the show it's a very
super synergist and a good that's
happening that's a great outlet thank
you everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate love to hear thoughts in the
comments below on the episode go and get
this license now gonna get
mediterraneans doubt as soon as we can
check out the full paper in nature as
well that's down there go follow david
on twitter and Errol scape on Twitter
for more of the information that they'll
be releasing soon and have more
conversation with your friends families
Congress people online about the future
of neuro technology in these closed-loop
digital meditations that can improve
their sustained attention shoutouts
around bagus we're producing and
directing thank you very much and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world support simulation
as well our links in the bio we love
very much we'll see you soon
peace
you